hold on okay she laughs yep what is it
they actually look like natural way I'm
Tom Geisel has done a bad example come
back oh nice like a visible attack see
with clarity hustle my my name is Gary
stop up I've been telling you
accountants of equity I'm sure when they
given a pedigree to mean and a pleasure
my faculties are putting the works on
I'm Darren are the moving furniture
[Music]
yes I couldn't work you want to drink I
got the hedges that works
no given by me I'll be in the booth
losers please
I got the ending that worse no you get
it I mean I put in work you don't want
to drink I got the essence of work
noggin get it like me I'm using a booth
please I gotta answer the worst noggin
get it like me the other route we can go
the other route we can go is level this
up make it more valuable to the people
and subsidize it you don't want it wait
I gotta ask that word fellow so I call
this meeting because I have this
ambition that I've not been able to
accomplish yet which is do a quarterly
or two times a year all hands on coun
Hall we're all it really is is one
massive Q&A session with me your timing
yes Venice yeah and you do that by being
developers correct as well it's my it's
why I win and that's what that's like
that's a dichotomy it's hard to grab
it's why I'm gonna be all-time great
right and so I think the same with lycra
when it comes to some we're talking to
you right it's like cool I want to be
about this company company's about this
company and it's about honey Empire if I
use helpless but I want I want people be
selfish that I'm comfortable at
I'm work I don't listen if you got the
distributions of the profit of
vaynermedia directly to your bank
account then you could be selfless like
I you how much fun I make fun of my
friends when they tell me things like
how do you get your employees to work as
hard as you I'm like you don't the [ __ ]
are you talking about you work for them
right I get that
a man look look at the wind because
we're even just having these
conversations right as one ship one
person here moved 30 percent in their
score of this place because of this
conversation and then you build on it
right like and then that leads to six
months from now something happening and
you come and talk to
and then the way I react to it changes
everything for you that's what we most
win the reason I want the one-on-one is
because what happens out of the
one-on-one not the what that's where
we're building trust it's all action
that's where we're winning
I love people who just want to stay in
their Lane maybe get one more two more
promotions haven't seen work/life
balance work nine to five
check out of here every day at 5:00 do
their work that's valuable
there's always an exchange I'm not going
to tell you how to live your life I just
want to provide a good trade for you for
that life place you want to work good
place the right at like you know what I
mean like I'm very
and by the way things change you're 24
you want to be CEO of vaynermedia you're
31 in loves one kid and you love like
taking her to soccer practice and you're
just not willing to work 18 hours a day
to be the CEO of intermedia solves it
for me we need them all I don't want to
be in charge your ambition I just want
to give you more than you give me
somebody you stay here forever you know
it's important that's real life that
means lacks ideological POVs and that is
just practical
thanks for how you can be a bikini be
awesome everything hi I'm here with Gary
Vaynerchuk CEO of vaynermedia investor
jack of many many times and host of the
widely popular ask Gary Vee show thanks
for being here today
make 405 global thank you so your
entrepreneurship goes way back lemonade
stands baseball cards and it turns out
you're going to be in 2047 the owners
adjust that's the plan
they're right choice so you say that
it's gonna be thirty years due to your
behavior yes I want her to embarrass say
that someone had told him what have you
were to condense that business plan that
lifetime
plan into it here yep what would that
look like for you it wouldn't look like
anything I cook like you know so funny
I answer every question always I'm sure
they're already laughing like I couldn't
even comprehend Matt it just it's just
not my wiring that's like asking me like
hey Gary what would have like how do you
start flying like a human it's
impossible
I'd have to I have to become a gambler
right like I'd have to take all my
assets and do something crazy
so I'm a marathon runner marathon
runners don't wind sprints you know they
just don't they don't have the body
shape for it they don't have the
mentality they don't train like that it
doesn't even feel good when you ask me
that and I genuinely believe that's
actually the reverse of most
entrepreneurs I think a lot of fake
entrepreneurs want to do this for the
watches and the private jets and the
champagne bottles and the boat and that
mm-hmm I just don't have it in me hi how
are you I mean guys it's been
unbelievable to watch entrepreneurship
like impact the whole world but
especially athletes and really artists I
think just really thinking so much
smarter and it's amazing I think what
like 15 years ago you guys like being
interested in this stuff was far less
than it is today and people really
thinking about off the field and like
somewhere around fourth grade I realized
I was more likely to buy the Jets than
play for them talk about everything that
you are so like like what what other
interests you have and you make how many
other I don't get to like it doesn't
really matter as long as it's your truth
it has to near truth
[Music]
just get back to do get back to us yeah
and what then what about the career from
social from the standpoint of what
happened on YouTube would happen on
Instagram what happened on Twitter what
happened like how do they give me the
narrative being a what
hopefully it's going to be big good good
martyr we get smarter baby how are they
gonna see R - s comfortable gonna see
again how was London Robin but from us
we are going through + tell me about
what how many understand where you guys
world's at like what tell me about your
career right now so they like come on
Jonesy shoulders no down basically this
is his life everything this is what
episode once or not 117 kid I know
what's your fun personal one right what
ring so what's our before you know I'm
not looking back
okay so welcome my man I got you the six
ring if you're in a state where once was
34 this is anyone something for once you
came out today came out today
yeah alright so one seven four is your
lucky number one so before bummer
let me get real if your state gets one
seven four and it's pick three today
send that in we got gifts for you so
once I decided back in know nine that it
was gonna pillar of our society I
started really really understanding the
business rationale but the bottom line
is and it's tried-and-true them it
happened long before hip hop when you
are yourself and you do not waiver you
will win if you're good enough
hmm
much love alright let's do it your
application
Instagram it turned into grand reaching
out I went down this whole path that I
never even knew existed and you're like
wait people pay me to put this product
in a picture with my child
[Music]
because I want this ila yeah really cool
okay so doing that and worked with a lot
of good brands I've been reaching out to
like some of my true brands ended up
working with within a year which I never
thought that just by damming them I put
together like a media kit something to
email to show them some of my sample
work and they you know gave me a shot
public sense of great and then
eventually end up getting paid so you
got one with Holograms for free and then
I had three month off and then one more
time it's different
yes had a record frame and introduced up
this conversation pisses me off the
amount of people that don't realize that
free of the gateway to paid I mean if
you're I mean it's the three of our
lives
it's a the audacity to think that you're
not being compensated when you're trying
to get a shot in a world where there's a
lot of photographers taking pictures of
their kids supply-and-demand
[ __ ]
that one's hoppiness
oh she can I really can't even really
good it's really European I would like
you man on this episode the legend stops
by Miguel to answer a question I've now
had a career for 20 plus years I every
minute was running one of two companies
Wine Library for vaynermedia there was
never a day in my life where I didn't
have something that I called the 80% of
what I do exactly what you were saying I
call it the meat the main dish you can
go and have side dishes and if your meat
if your steak is perfect you'll always
be able to absorb the losses because
they're smaller losses and then when
something over here becomes bigger you
can turn that into the main part and
that could become the steak too many
people have all side dishes and no steak
what'd I miss take a step back to
highlight be coming up to me when we die
- he waited till my equal to high
library chilling in a fantasy with my
five five [ __ ] but she just super Wi-Fi
superficial cheating coming listen Tony
dude desired achievement horizon John
large run the [ __ ] they providing my
thoughts I'd never have a herd of
silence tonight when we found a nine to
five you watch do this [ __ ] then like
five to nine and then I signed a Viper's
on I don't know if I got time to keep
trying to rhyme and I dream about seeds
in the fence wherever I get paid in
advance and I'm the man and the ticket
can meet the demands I'm also vegan
monster [ __ ] fired up a bit quiet for
last-minute things with something you
know that I've said I have about it
nothing like good climbing
they were good and when we die - I want
to do with you and so I'm willing to do
it for less but if a fake brand red eye
things that are not scalable that are
about brand and that's why I think I'm
winning only at the top of all these
high-rises and I don't see why we drop
open eyelids the concidered adjacent
horizon the job bars rather [ __ ]
labor oddly hemotoxic first I did a lot
of things before I took it over
so I spent years chipping away at him
trusting me so that he could give me as
much room as possible to do my things so
sometimes kids go to university never
work in the business or do different
things and they may just show up as an
adult and so you're starting to be so
what's your situation so you're in that
situation yeah so have you worked in the
business before so that's the part I
don't know like I don't know how much
all you want is air cover to do what you
believe in and all the parent wants is
their own balance of how much they
believe and don't believe in the kid how
much they believe in don't believe in
the direction and how much they still
have in their tank we finally figured
out how to bring value to small
businesses and so that's a scoop oh by
the way I got another idea
I'd love to get this guy's you know give
them Zappos be this thing I've been
thinking about doing a 12 hour digital
media detox
tour at vaynermedia for $10,000 a head
where you come in at 9:00 a.m. breakfast
there's a lunch keynote something's in
here on Sundays I'm not basically go
through all our disciplines I would
basically do a one-day consulting sesh
for 10k where it's all based around the
Vayner world you tour here different
days you meet executives like you know I
don't know if you guys noticed but we
have old people too like we have that
really thinking about this concept like
Disney and Zappos does where you spend
12 hours at vaynermedia for $10,000 a
head
I really think we can make it valuable
when I look at what people are doing for
like 10,000 off like really trying to
figure this out so if you're interested
in 10k see a bunch of you already
answering that you are send me an email
I promise you you'll be
first people before I announce it
officially that will you'll be in the
first beta run when your Tuggle wine why
do you want to dig into the family
difference because I'm getting my family
with them yes your potential oh how big
you can explode it okay and why some
what's pulling you on the nonprofit
because there there's somebody that
needs yes yes no help me you know you
can't really like them so I think
there's two to two debates equal so ha
legacy huh love it uh is a fifty-fifty
you know yeah right this second
nonprofit you should did not drop it
heals just regret as you don't mean
either meetings over
it's just obvious it seemed like there
that's what it was for me like that's
where I thought you were going to go and
if you answered fifty-fifty I was
literally gonna tell you to flip a coin
and never look back but I love the you
answered 6040 because that's what I felt
what's happening just got that wasn't my
guess I wish I wrote it down it'll cool
off for the camera you should do it well
if you're truly fifty I hate people
sitting on [ __ ] and I think there's
times when there's fifty fifty I have it
I don't have a coin I just literally
just say to myself it's stupid this and
I just go so there is trends for fifty
fifty the problem is 99% of people are
sitting on fifty-fifty their whole
[ __ ] life which means they're zero
zero so when you're fifty fifty you get
one day and anything else is you're just
[ __ ] sitting in bullshitting so
[ __ ] flip a coin to pick the one
never look back but you're truly 6040
don't spend any more time
don't underestimate speed in action
moving is important because you can
change the course
you can stop doing it if you don't give
a [ __ ] about what people think you can
do everything I know that's why I told
you so guys go do the [ __ ] NGO you'll
never regret you another thing back the
lumber companies going to be there dad's
doing this thing and after four months
if you don't like the way it tastes so
you're like luck there so if you see
what I mean yeah
but the quicker you start the quicker
you do good do it go all end up ok no
more no more brain power to hear like
should I do the lumber thing just go all
in and and then do and watch be in it
and watch yourself from above and just
use consoling move I can change it I
gotta go
thank you you got any work to do I know
you guys watch it off you guys what to
do he's great but in the future I'll get
out there shaking [ __ ] cool and when we
die - then you step back to highlight be
coming up to me when we die - he waited
till the morning book to highlight rich
killing in a fantasy with my socks off
[ __ ] but super Wi-Fi superficial she
coming with me trust us only at the top
of all these high-rises and I don't see
always rock open Islands